couple more clips to play for you two
days ago i told you that my pillow mike
lindell's phone was seized by the fbi a
phone is a type of machine we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yesterday we looked at the
search warrant for
pillow and all of the things that were
on the search warrant and then today i
just have a few clips from for you
of mike pillow really off the rails now
after this fbi seizure take a look at
this here he is on steve bannon's show i
told the fbi guy steve i told the fbi
guys i said that you guys are going to
be on my six o'clock show
on frank's speech and and they said this
corrupt investigation whatever you're
trying to do and they go mike we're just
doing our jobs i said yeah i said the
corruption goes back to our government
yeah hold on hold on hold on stop stop
stop stop stop stop i want all the fbi
people out there we got whistleblowers
all over the place that phrase is not
going to save you that's what the waffen
ss said that's what the gestapo said to
save themselves after 1945
[Laughter]
oh dear they claim to be tough on crime
and yet they have no problem calling law
enforcement nazis that's essentially
what bannon is saying he's saying oh
yeah the fbi is saying the same thing
that uh that nazis were saying after
world war ii
um one other clip here about the cell
phone well anyway then he says here it
comes he goes well after about 25
minutes to talk and he goes mike we have
to take your cell phone by the way this
is from a different interview with
charlie kirk and i go you're not getting
my cell phone i said i'd rather be
arrested i said arrest me you're not
getting my phone i don't even i don't
use a computer this is all of my this is
my by the way what do you think happens
to the phone if you get arrested if you
get arrested they take all the stuff
that's in your pockets my businesses my
lindo recovery network this is my
thousands of employees that i i said
they were like we all rely on this i
said what would you need my phone for
and you can't have my phone he goes well
we got a subpoena right here for your
phone um signed by a judge and i'm going
okay um
um i'm gonna can i call my attorney or
one of my attorneys he goes no they goes
he goes i said i can't call my attorney
and you think i'm to give you my phone
if i don't give you my phone am i going
to be arrested he said no but we are
going to take the phone i said well then
i want to call my attorney finally he
says you call your attorney my attorney
one of my attorneys gets out and goes
mike just give him the phone and i said
i would rather get arrested i said
everybody relies on this yeah anyway he
doesn't seem to realize that they take
your phone if you get arrested too and
then lastly pillow says that at a trump
rally this weekend he is going to
uh i don't know address everything in
some way i'm gonna be with the at the at
the president our real president's rally
in ohio on saturday i'm gonna speak
there about this we go now we have a
unique opportunity everybody to spread
the word get the word out maybe maybe
steve that just once that the media
would go um hey mike why why did they do
this to you uh could it be because i
have all the evidence
because i want to get rid of voting
machines and electronic computers in our
elections that's what it is we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines anyway so pillow completely uh
his brain broke as a result of this
seizure and we'll see what uh is going
on next week with it truly incredible
stuff
monday 9 19 it is membership promo day
last chance get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
to get notified monday of this beautiful
membership special